difficile d'acheter ces protections
hygiéniques quand on est étudiante
face à la précarité menstruel des
étudiants en médecine de l'université
versailles saint quentin en décidé
d'agir grâce à poèmes leur association
des protections seront bientôt
distribuées aux étudiantes une
distribution ça dure toute une journée
et on va classer les différentes
protections avec des affiches pour
expliquer comment fonctionne chaque
protection quels sont ses avantages et
ses inconvénients et on laissera du coup
les étudiants de choisir et elles
pourront faire un don libre en fonction
de ce qu'elle pense et ce qu'elle
aimerait donner des subventions de l'ue
vs cul du crous et la fage ont permis
d'acheter pour soixante mille euros de
serviettes lavables et jetable de tampon
et de cup
cette action fait suite à un sondage
réalisé en février 2020 c'est ressorti
qu'il y avait à peu près 20%
d'étudiantes qui avait dû bricoler une
prothèse une fortune par manque de
moyens à ce moment là donc c'est assez
énorme sur ce campus est à peu près neuf
pour cent des étudiantes ont déjà dû
choisir entre acheter soit des
protections mensuels soit un autre
produit de première nécessité comme par
exemple de la nourriture par la suite
l'association aimerait aussi étendre ses
actions
organiser des ateliers pour apprendre à
coudre ses propres protection lavables
ou encore intervenir dans les écoles
pour lever les tabous sur les monstres
ulation